first of all I want to say thank you
everyone's a fan a serious fan I'm
keeping my cool right now even when you
walked in but we're all super big fans
here and I'm gonna be chill about it but
I wanted to do something sweet for you
so we made it a little afternoon delight
spot of tea because it's about the Brits
view so feel free pour in the coffee my
favorite I think traditionally the
coffee pot is the slightly taller one
the belly of this allows the tea to
bruise the leaves to prove to get a
full-bodied yeah that's my favorite way
I love it I love it we're learning oh
can I have some of that all right I
didn't bring you here just a sip some
tea I wanted to spill some tea so I
thought of a game I like to call it sip
it and spill and it's basically a very
sophisticated version of never have I
ever so I'm trying to keep something
very American and trashy classy but for
example sip it and spill it if you've
ever lost your self in a bathroom of the
glass of wine because you have children
you just want a minute to yourself see
then I would take this bad boy and I'd
drink the high-hat you drink that way
okay spill it
if you've ever rolled Easter eggs while
wearing a bonnet and dress you were born
adoption oh my friend said put on our
dress and let's roll Easter egg down the
hill so we drew this makes you my
favorite person at the table I know once
again okay wait here
zip it and spill it if you've ever snobs
Brad Pitt snob means kissed right are
you about your tea
well I'm just fit me in it we just go
story somebody had to pay job because we
were on a set put up any other page yes
see there are worse ways to earn a
living so I was not complaining but yeah
he cut his teeth okay and Spillers if
you've ever put on a Downton costume or
any costume backwards what do you mean
how did you used to happen a lot because
sometimes the costumes are the same on
the front as they are in the back so
there'd be like an embellishment on the
front and you know slightly may be
buried pattern on the back but you can't
really tell the difference so um it
happened a few times how far did you go
with it I mean I actually when the deals
really right and the backs a little Oh
sip it and spill it if after a night of
wild carousing you ended up sleeping in
your trailer on the set of Downton Ave
[Laughter]
[Music]
long day during summer where we have a
light refreshment so we got very very
refreshed on hard cider called old Rosie
she's a cruel mistress because she was
fun she drink so I had the great idea
just go back to the castle I'll sleep in
the castle more like in my trader then
so basically I'll be ready for work or
just roll out of the trailer but the
problem is there's a 15 foot gate I did
it wasn't the greatest idea I've ever
had something out it's pitch black like
you can't even begin to distract because
there's not like I once tried I drove
myself one day to the set all I had to
do was drive to the gate I couldn't even
find the gate did the car not have
headlights yeah it had headlights but
they went like about two feet she was in
a ditch and the wheels were spinning and
I couldn't get I couldn't actually get
out of it
spill it if you've ever fallen out of
your tiny pair of Speedos from interims
while on set
[Music]
why are you wearing Speedos
it wasn't on damp though one of my first
jobs the people who were doing the
costumes wrote said Oh a young boy and
his father I was 17 so when I arrived
all of the speedos were like four eight
or nine so then I'm like we don't have
time just we're gonna have to you know
just you're gonna have to try and fit
into one of them and then it won't take
they went and okay just just hold there
what's the problem they were just you're
em wait what is that because I actually
don't know what that adds a fake fake do
you just eat it like that I've only seen
it's like a spread or so sorry real
technique if you've had the greatest
time
exactly you never do that I will not
stop talking until you subscribe to my
YouTube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this